hey Brian hey Danny hey so you've got a
new macbook there that I do Wow now
these just came out a few weeks ago and
this is the the 13.3 43 with the new
aluminum casing there's actually a lot
that's new on this the size is the same
they redesigned even the battery which
somehow looks it looks like it somehow
it looks like a looks almost like a
iphone yes like from the past like I
feel like I could be like hello hello
and this is this is interesting because
they this is a new production process
they used on this case this is milled
from one solid piece of aluminum right
top portion is there's no seams at all
actually you can tell picking this up
it's feels like the most solid laptop
you've ever felt it's actually a pound
lighter than the first macbooks this is
4.5 pounds so we got a new glass screen
LED screen origin it is quite nice and a
new laser glass etched trackpad yeah
there's a yeah it's gone yeah so there's
the entire trackpad is like one big
large solid button and this is something
that actually I heard about it we
followed the announcement we blogged
about it i thought i was going to
actually hate i thought i was going to
hate it too but when i first used it it
was actually felt really natural yeah
but i did you find the same the same
thing i did actually there well the
first week or so of using it there's
there's no difference basically it
slopes down slightly and you still get a
physical click when you push on it now
that everywhere on the track that I was
just naturally just pushing down here
towards the bottom can you kind of push
on it anywhere you can that's one of the
other new things it is this trackpad is
now well you'll notice it's
substantially bigger than the old ones
but it also supports up to four fingers
of gesture controls so for instance
expose is tracked to this and you can
actually by swiping up with four fingers
move everything off the screen three
fingers will actually if you have a
webpage open and if you swipe to the
right or left will go
forward and backward so there's no
firewire port on here at all Apple
decided to leave it off Apple likes to
sort of a discontinued features maybe
before they're ready to to die before
the grapple actually created helped
create the firewire spec which is kind
of ironic and then I got rid of it now
it should be noted that the firewire is
only gone on the macbook version the pro
still has firewire 800 it has firewire
800 on there you actually went out and
bought this you traded in your old map
book where you sold them pro yeah yes he
sold sold your macbook pro and then
bought this computer instead comparing
the two together what would you what
would you give this this computer I
would have to say I'd give it a nine
this is one of the best laptops I've
used in quite a while so we benchmark
tested the new macbook pro in the new
macbook and we compare that to the
scores on the old macbook and the old
macbook pro the new macbook with
top-line spec actually beak the old
macbook pro in terms of performance it
actually be both Mac yes did ya which
may have been an anomaly or not but and
X bench isn't a perfect indicator
performance but it's noteworthy
nonetheless and this marks a huge step
between the top of the line the black
macbook and this new version this thing
just tears interest is just it's a speed
demon it is yeah yeah makes me want to
raise it speed racer speed racer
this is the canon vixia hf 10 and this
is a high-definition camcorder that
shoots straight to a flash hard drive
contained within it no tape required and
did really well on our fault test issue
didn't Jose that's right it won the best
of tests then he got nine out of ten
that blue balls that's a great Aang yeah
so yeah this is actually one of the
best-looking and the you know best
functioning little camcorders that we
played with it's very small I really
appreciate that even though the shoots
high definition video at 1920 x 1080
pixels ah it's very compact it's even
smaller than standard definition
camcorders were just a couple years ago
so they'll know one of the bad things
about it you know in this really kind of
glowing review is that the battery kind
of sucks yeah about an hour you might be
able to get an hour in 20 minutes if
you're lucky but it's you know it's not
that long so you're gonna have to carry
your cord around or buy a bunch of extra
batteries then exactly another
significant downside to this if you're a
Mac user you need OS 10 10.5 otherwise
known as leopard any version earlier
than that and you're not going to be
able to transfer movies from this to
your computer this is great camcorder I
have no hesitation recommending it and i
would say at the price that it's at list
price is about eleven hundred dollars
but you can find it on amazon for about
600 right this is it great buy if you're
thinking of making the jump to high
definition or tapeless video recording
this is definitely the product to do it
in a little tip the hf 100 is a sibling
camcorder to this one identical in every
way except it has no memory on board so
you can only use it with SD cards right
and that's one hundred dollars cheaper
so if you got some SD cards laying
around great choice i think it's a deal
at that price yes oh so canon hf 10 it's
a great camcorder as you like a lot